(loud buzzing)
(high intensity music)
- I'm on board with this.
- God damn it.
(buzzing)
- Oh, can I not even do that?
- I mean, it just leaves me mouth, right?
- [Man] Feel like I'm gonna hurt myself.
(blowing air)
- Nope, that didn't work. (giggling)
- [Man] Easy.
(breathing heavily)
- It just doesn't make any sense.
(squirting, laughing)
- Oh, okay.
- [Man] Get it, get it, just go for it!
Go for it, kid!
Touchdown!
(spitting)
(snorting, coughing)
- (gurgling) Mmm.
- That coffee is in the cup.
Let's get some creamer.
Boom!
(spitting)
(slurping)
Ah, a little cold.
(upbeat music)
(techno music)
♫ Junk food cocktails ♫
♫ Just wanted to let you know
♫ You're sexy
♫ As fuck ♫
- [Voiceover] Gavon, was
today a good day or bad day?
(fast paced music)
- It was a terrible day.
- [Voiceover] Why?
- Because the White
House is casting doubts
on North Korea's claim that it detonated
an H bomb so the only way to get to the
bottom of this is to send
basketball ambassador
Dennis Rodman over there, but if in fact
there was a nuclear bomb
detonated over there
he may become irradiated and turn into
a giant man-eating worm.
Humanity is doomed.
(upbeat, bouncy music)